this here is an austere Cod it's a funny
little thing isn't it there are about 70
thousand species of these tiny
crustaceans around today
but this is a fossilized example scans
using a synchrotron a kind of x-ray
machine on steroids the synchrotron
allows scientists to peer inside the
ostracod shell a preserved soft tissue
and there they found something
interesting
giant fossilized sperm
[Music]
this is a cross-section through one of
these tiny animals the dots you can see
a slices through the sperm when stacked
together the sections combine to show 3d
chunks of long sperm cells very long
sperm cells typically ostracods are only
around a millimeter long but in the
sperm Department they're far from tiny
often producing sperm cells ten times
longer than their own bodies these giant
sperm are at least 16 million years old
making them the oldest gametes ever
discovered but they're not the biggest
the most super-sized sperm in the animal
kingdom are found in fruit flies
véra whopping 5 centimeters but they're
thought to have evolved very recently
and very quickly this fossil suggests
that ostracods have been in the giant
sperm game for much longer for reason
scientists don't fully understand their
extraordinary gametes must have been
around for well over 16 million years it
seems that for ostracods at least it's
not just sized but experienced that
really counts
[Music]